[Musik]
wie werden wir uns im jahre 2050
ernähren was essen wir in zukunft zehn
milliarden menschen werden dann den
planeten bevölkern uns alle mit genügend
nahrung zu versorgen eine globale
herausforderung so wie heute können wir
uns wahrscheinlich in 30 jahren nicht
mehr ernähren
die umwelt würde unseren fleischkonsum
die monokulturen unseren enormen
wasserverbrauch kaum aushalten müssen
wir also alle vegetarier werden oder
insekten essen kommt unser fleisch bald
nur noch aus dem labor
unsere esskultur hat sich über
jahrhunderte entwickelt es wird schwer
werden sich einzustellen auf den
speiseplan der zukunft werden wir zehn
milliarden menschen im jahr 2050 mit
einer biologischen landwirtschaft
ernähren können oder ist es eine utopie
verträumter ökos im auftrag der
welternährungsorganisation fao legen die
wissenschaftler adrian müller und
christian scheider vom institut für
biologischen landbau schweiz nun eine
erste umfassende studie vor mit
erschreckenden ergebnissen
also unsere brechen haben ergeben dass
werden was sie vielmehr land brauchen
und das wäre eine dramatische
veränderung wenn wir so weiter
produziert worden wie wir das heute tun
also das ist eigentlich nicht möglich
wenn wir so weitermachen so ihr fazit
können wir die menschheit wieder mit
einer biologischen noch mit einer
konventionellen landwirtschaft
problemlos ernähren
für die berechnung haben die
wissenschaftler die entscheidenden
aspekte einbezogen
zb die konsumgewohnheiten die sich
weltweit dem westlichen lebensstil
anpassen
schon heute haben vor allem in
asiatischen ländern immer mehr menschen
lust auf milch und fleisch mit der folge
dass der bedarf an tierischen
lebensmitteln enorm steigt einen
drastischen anstieg von futtermitteln um
das wirklich zu produzieren und damit
einhergehende einfach an den
umweltschäden die das zur folge haben
würde
derzeit liegt der weltweite
fleischkonsum bei 320 millionen tonnen
früher im jahr 2050 wird es eineinhalb
mal so viel sein
auch der bedarf an eiern und milch wird
dramatisch steigen
einbezogen haben die wissenschaftler
auch den klimawandel der durch
starkregen oder extreme trockenheit zu
enormen ertragseinbußen führen wird
doch wie wird das berechnet des klimas
ist das 3d im schnitt einfach tiefer
sein werden da gibt es vorhersagen die
sorge der träger werden gar nicht mehr
steigen oder sogar niedriger sein als
heute
und wir haben so ein mittelwert quasi
genommen dass der träger doch noch
ansteigen aber lange nicht so stark wie
die mv das vorher sagt wie viel nahrung
werden wir also benötigen und wie viel
wird uns zur verfügung stehen wenn die
welt sich weiter unserem westlichen
lebensstandard anpasst haben wir im jahr
2050 einen täglichen bedarf von 30
millionen kalorien
der ertrag aber wird deutlich niedriger
ausfallen um diesen großen bedarf zu
stehen bräuchten wir in jedem fall mehr
land für eine konventionelle
landwirtschaft fehlen 20 prozent
ackerfläche für eine biologische sogar
60 dort stellt sich die leute woher das
kommt wir haben eigentlich kein monster
dass wir zusätzlich neben können ohne
dass wir massiv mehr entlassen werden
oder massiv mehr grasland dann verlieren
würden mit entsprechenden schlimmen
folgen für die situation weiter wie also
soll die welternährung langfristig
gesichert werden
für christian scheider nicht nur mit
einer steigerung der produktion die
landwirtschaftliche produktion ist in
den meisten westlichen ländern und da
war auch in vielen anderen ländern schon
sehr stark optimiert das heißt das
natürliche potenzial lebensmittel auf
einer gewissen fläche zu produzieren
weitgehend ausgereizt und daher muss man
sich überlegen ob man andere hebel hat
im ganzen ernährungssystem um das
problem effektiver anzugehen
deshalb nehmen die wissenschaftler auch
den konsum unter die lupe und schlagen
zwei strategien vor
es ist absurd wenn man nur an ertrag
steigerung denkt um die welternährung
problematik zu lösen und gleichzeitig
ein drittel bis die hälfte der
lebensmittel weggeworfen werden
die erste strategie also weniger
lebensmittelverschwendung dieser abfall
reduktion wurde 30 prozent mehr kalorien
bringen
bei der zweiten strategie geht's um
fleisch die wissenschaftler nennen diese
strategie fiedler futter keine
nahrungsmittel
die tiere sollen kein futter mehr
bekommen das den menschen als nahrung
dienen könnte
denn wenn der mensch die pflanzen erst
an das tier verfüttert und dann das
fleisch ist gehen auf diesem weg viele
wertvolle kalorien verloren wenn er soja
mais und weizen direct essen würde
erhielte er deutlich mehr kalorien
ungefähr 20 prozent deshalb sollen die
tiere wie in der traditionellen
tierhaltung üblich ausschließlich gras
und abfallprodukte fressen kompletter
fleischverzicht ist aber auch keine
lösung denn zwei drittel des globalen
agrarland es sind weidefläche weil der
boden zu karg oder so uneben ist taugt
er nicht als ackerland vielmehr als gras
wächst hier nicht um dieses grasland zu
nutzen für die menschliche ernährung
sind eben wiederkäuer wie beispielsweise
kühe schafe ziegen ein wichtiges element
um aus gras menschliche menschliche
nahrung hessen stellen die noch zudem
einen hohen proteingehalt hat diese
ressource muss also genutzt werden um
die welternährung zu sichern
dennoch ihre vorschläge bedeuten
deutlich weniger fleischkonsum
wir wissen nicht kein fleisch mehr essen
wenn jetzt die hälfte fleisch ging das
ist schon drastisch aber machbar würde
ich sagen das geht nicht darum extreme
zu realisieren es geht darum einfach
einen guten schritt in die richtige
richtung zu gehen
aus den berechnungen geht hervor wenn
man konventionell anbauen wollte müsste
man zum beispiel fiedler food zu 50
prozent umsetzen wenn man die welt
biologisch ernähren wollte müsste man
fit not sogar zu 100 prozent umsetzen
und den abfall um 50 prozent reduzieren
eine komplette umstellung auf
biologische landwirtschaft wäre also
möglich
doch ob bio oder konventionell alle
berechnungen bedeuten einen drastischen
einschnitt in unseren konsum
wir haben keine andere wahl eigentlich
wir müssen das wir erreichen und wenn
wir die menschheit irgendwie so ernähren
wollen dass wir auf diesen planeten
quasi weiterhin wie sinnvoll
wirtschaften können und werden wir das
nicht tun haben wir sowieso keine chance
der aufruf der wissenschaftler ist klar
die vorschläge eindeutig noch ist es
nicht zu spät um die welternährung der
zukunft zu sichern
in den vergangenen 50 jahren als sich
der fleischkonsum weltweit verdreifacht
mit ziemlich fatalen folgen für die
umwelt und besonders gesund ist es auch
nicht die deutsche gesellschaft für
ernährung rät dazu noch halb so viel
fleisch zu essen
was also tun hier liegt ein teil der
lösung
denn hier gibt es ihnen den bürger von
beyond mit exakt 113 gramm labor fleisch
aus pflanzen leonardo dicaprio und bill
gates haben in das start-up investiert
anfang mai 2009 10 ging das
kalifornische unternehmen an die börse
die aktien verkauften sich wie warme
semmeln bier und mied gelang einer der
erfolgreichsten börsengänge seit 20
jahren bei den fleisch ersatzprodukten
geht es ja nicht nur darum den geschmack
von fleisch zu imitieren sondern das
besonders schwierige meiner ansicht nach
ist auch die konsistenz zu votieren
also im kunden das gefühl zu geben würde
ich unsere bürger weiße das auch
wirklich fleisch drin ist der bitburger
der wis angeblich geschafft haben alex
bereitet gerade eine hallo was ist denn
in den be on package wird alles drin
also zum größten ich bin hier natürlich
was gab's ein putin basis mit rote bete
saft dann ist soll
kokosöl eine natürliche rohstoffe und
unter die inhaltsstoffe durch sehr lang
habe der hauptbestandteil wir natürlich
erstens ist der drang der leute oder der
wunsch der leute mal auf fleischlos zu
essen scheint groß zu sein dieses bei
ihren kunden kommen da er so
fleischesser die mal etwas vegetarisches
wollen oder vegetarier die heiß darauf
sind irgendwas im mund zu haben was ich
dann doch so anfühlt nach lancia also es
kommt natürlich unser publikum ist der
bild gemischt also wir haben die veganer
vegetarier werden auch gleich die
veganer natürlich probieren alle wege
hat natürlich diesem bürger aus weil er
halt so gehabt es gibt natürlich auch
fleisch das er die ideen ausprobieren
und auch sagen dass ein mega gut ist
also eher kommt schon sehr anderen sagen
also ist immer gemischte gefühle aber
wir haben auch natürlich auch gleich
veganer bei uns drin
die dann einmal probiert haben ihre
haben heute gesagt haben dass michael
douglas bekommt viel zu sehr an den
fleischgeschmack für die brasilianer
warum wollen die leute eigentlich
unbedingt dieses fleisch oder diesen
eher sachs wegen auch vegetarier sind
oft ziemlich heimathaus irgendwas zu
haben was sich wenigstens so anfühlen
fleisch ich denke das ist so dass die
die veganer oder vegetarier auf diesen
diesem fleischgeschmack einfach sehr
gerne hat sich einen dritten veganer und
vegetarier wollte weil es ihm nicht
schmeckt man wird die ethisch moralisch
und veganer und daher denke ich
natürlich
dass man diesen fleischgeschmack
irgendwie vermisst und da darf deswegen
suchten sie suchen sich die vegetarier
oder veganer und scheint wahrscheinlich
mache ja genau so fleischer dass
produkte die annähernd so gut sind oder
eine geschmack eines wichtigen anderen
wichtigen rindfleisch oder sie sind
bürger ran zu kommen
was ist denn eigentlich das besonders
schwierige beim herstellen von solchen
fleisch und aas
das schwierige ist man darf sich
natürlich gericht an einem richtigen
preis festhalten
also man darf das nicht machen wichtige
freiwilliger freitag
das mit berlin ist natürlich ein
bisschen weiter wie ein normales bewegt
und verhält sich auch so also man kann
sie selbst wenn ich dass die antworten
soll unten und sollten wir uns einen
schönen ausblick baten um von beiden
seiten auch aber man kommt nie ganz
durch also ist es immer gut ist immer so
ein bisschen blut ist ein typisches well
done bürger was eigentlich auch nicht
gut sein sollte
klickt man kriegt noch nicht wirklich
das ist immer ein bisschen kuscheln ist
immer ein bisschen sagt ich okay jetzt
richtig zu den anja da kommt er jetzt
dasselbe drauf wie man aus der
nationalliga ganz ganz schlecht ganz
simpel überwiegend klassischen
cheeseburger kortison johannes klaus
dafür ketchup ein bisschen klatsch ab
aber nur so ein kleines bisschen
das finde ich echt gespannt auf das
gaben erfüllen ich halte noch einmal
rein das ist das letzte mal dass sie
diesen bürger in dieser form noch sehen
das kommt im fleisch wirklich sehr sehr
nah muss sagen neuesten studien zufolge
könnte der absatz von fleisch in die tat
in den nächsten jahren explosionsartig
wachsen bis 2040 erwarten manche studien
dass 60 prozent des jetzigen
fleischkonsums durch fleisch und a-tec
gedeckt werden und die entwicklung gehen
da immer weiter und eigentlich liegt es
nur noch an preis er ist eines der
beliebtesten gerichte weltweit allein
bei den beiden größten fastfood-ketten
gehen jedes jahr mehr als fünf
milliarden bürger über den tisch
millionen tonnen fleisch werden
produziert mit enormen kosten bis zu 50
prozent der für die erderwärmung
verantwortlichen treibhausgase sollen
aus der viehhaltung stammen
wir wissen dass die menschheit damit
anfangen muss weniger fleisch zu essen
in die fleischproduktion ist sehr
schlecht für uns am planeten weil sie so
viel treibhausgase produziert werden wir
in zukunft noch ohne schlechtes gewissen
in einen blutigen burger beißen können
ist dieser blutige hightech veggie
burger die lösung im silicon valley
arbeiten sie daran
acht jahre haben sie bei impossible fuß
daran geforscht einen blutigen burger
und fleisch herzustellen
bill gates und google haben 180
millionen dollar in das startup
investiert setzen auf ein riesengeschäft
ich sehe uns als geburtsstätte eine
industrie die die weltweite
lebensmittelproduktion grundlegend
verändern wird und das ist der stoff der
alles verändern soll
künstliches blut basierend auf dem
molekül hin
es kommt in fast allen lebensformen vor
ohnehin gebe es kein leben bei mensch
und tier ist das molekül für den
sauerstofftransport im blut
verantwortlich aber es hat noch eine
andere eigenschaft
wir haben als erste herausgefunden dass
heim auch dafür sorgt dass fleisch nach
fleisch schmeckt das molekül gibt es
reichlich empirischen muskelgewebe und
sorgt für den blutigen geschmack wenn
man fleisch ist mischt man das künstlich
hergestellte dem blut mit einer art
pflanzen püree aus weizen kartoffeln und
kokosöl kommt dabei etwas heraus dass
nicht nur aussieht wie frisches
hackfleisch sondern auch so schmeckt so
sehen es jedenfalls die kunden der mehr
als 1.000 restaurants in den usa in
denen der impossible burger mittlerweile
verkauft wird die konsistenz war wie
beim echten fleisch ich habe nicht
gemerkt dass es ein pflanzen burger horn
das ist cool dass jetzt auch vegetarier
solche bürger aus ich würde
aber können die blutigen veggie burger
eines tages die milliarden fleischklops
ersetzen
die jeden tag auf den brettern landen
ein teil wird von der
produktionskapazitäten abhängen
wir wissen noch nicht ob sie es schaffen
werden für den massenmarkt zu
produzieren aber genau daran arbeiten
sie bei impossible food und große mengen
des blutigen fleischlosen bürgers
rentabel zu produzieren wird das
künstliche blut industriell hergestellt
und das geht nur mit moderner gentechnik
aus den knollen der sojapflanze wird dna
entnommen und in hefezellen
eingeschleust aus denen wird dann das
künstliche blut gewonnen
das klima retten durchgehend technik das
nächste große projekt bisherigen werden
brot und brötchen das kennt und liebt
der deutsche kunde
wahrscheinlich wird er sich aber ein
anderes gewöhnen müssen an insekten
reich an proteinen und vitaminen stehen
sie in vielen ländern auf der täglichen
speisekarte zwei milliarden menschen
essen regelmäßig insekten vor allen
dingen in asien und lateinamerika
schon jetzt gibt es auch bei uns im
supermarkt verschiedene angebote mit
insekten bisher nur als mail den wahren
beigemischt zum beispiel in nudeln oder
protein riegeln das wird sich ändern
sechs beine fühler facettenaugen
manchmal auch noch ein paar flüge die
rede ist von insekten hierzulande eher
mit reichlich ekel verbunden sind solche
krabbeltiere in fernen ländern auf der
täglichen speisekarte
die statistik sagt zwei milliarden
menschen essen regelmäßig insekten vor
allem in asien afrika und lateinamerika
auch wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
irgendwann in zukunft insekten zu essen
heißt es wenn die weltbevölkerung weiter
wächst auf 9 milliarden und das sagt
auch die un kommen wir gar nicht drum
rum alternative als proteinquellen zu
finden und eine alternative
proteinquelle sind insekten als
nahrungsmittel 1900 essbare insekten
gibt es weltweit das fleisch der zukunft
wer weiß sie liefern hochwertiges
protein sind fettärmer als andere
eiweißlieferanten und stehen beim gehalt
an vitaminen und spurenelementen den
herkömmlichen fleischarten nicht nach
was kaum bekannt ist auch wir essen
schon krabbeltiere unbewusst fast jeden
tag eine amerikanische studie spricht
von 500 gramm pro kopf und jahr als
rückstände in lebensmitteln wie ketchup
müssen oder schokolade deklariert muss
das weil gesundheitlich unbedenklich
nicht werden
es gibt viele produkte zb ketchup er
wurde früher natürlich nicht die beste
tomate genommen sondern tomaten wo
vielleicht insekten sind und somit
kommen sekten unserem nahrungsmitteln
der pforzheimer unternehmer will
insekten als nahrungsmittel voranbringen
der anfang ist gemacht mit nudeln und
spätzle in denen gemahlene käferlarven
verarbeitet werden
weizen kriegs oder mail ist die basis
dazu kommen zehn viel aus gemahlenen
buffalo würmern die tierchen erhöhen so
den anteil wertvolle eiweiße in den
nudeln
wir wollen mit einer niedrigen
hemmschwelle jedem ermöglichen die das
essen die zukunft zu probieren wir haben
zehn prozent insekten maile in ganz
alltägliche lebensmittel wie zum
beispiel nudeln keksen oder die sondern
die familie gemeinsam verzehren können
in diesem böblingen supermarkt gibt es
die wurm nudeln schon der absatz ist
eher gering
die meisten kunden bevorzugen klassische
wurm freie teigwaren gedanken daran dass
das insekten sind viel eiweiß
wahrscheinlich ihre weise
obwohl ich stecken es pro jahr
die farbe macht den unterschied die
nudeln mit insekten sind dunkler als
klassische teigwaren und haben kleine
partikel in teig optisch vergleichbar
mit vollkornnudeln das denn für viele
eklig ist es aber gar nichts sagen
testesser in diesem vorteil lokal bieten
wir die insekten passt müssen wir jetzt
ja vollkommen speck gleichmäßig und aber
es ist gut das ist einfach nur gut ja
manchmal muss man seinen horizont
einfach erweitern
die wohnungen sind nicht billig knapp
vier euro das pfund der grund die
insekten sind teuer weil sie in einer
insekten waren aufwändig gezüchtet und
zu mehl verarbeitet werden
hygienisch lebensmittel technisch
einwandfrei und streng kontrolliert
dennoch schrecken würmer er ab also dass
ich menschen in unserem kulturkreis ekel
ist ja verständlich ist denn hier
sozialisiert aufgewachsen
wenn das verdirbt und stehen vielleicht
maden und ist auch ein zeichen dafür
dass etwas nicht essbar ist aber die
marken die wir verwenden das sind
speziell gezüchtete jeder hoch
kontrollierten anlagen sehr moderne
speziell für den menschlichen verzehr
auf insekten als nahrung hierzulande den
durchbruch schaffen
viele sind skeptisch trotz bester
bewertung als nahrungsmittel alles was
kriegt oder krabbelt stößt die meisten
doch noch ab außer kinder
die gehen mit solchen leckereien
irgendwie viel lockerer als erwachsene
nicht nur insekten sind eine alternative
zum fleischkonsum auch direkt vor
unserer haustür laufen und delikatessen
über den weg die hier eigentlich nicht
hingehören
wenn es um die probleme der ernährung
der zukunft geht da könnte dieser kleine
kerl hier eine ziemlich große rolle
spielen was kann der amerikanische rote
sumpf krebs denn für uns tun
der russe amerikanischen sumpf krebs
gehört zu den invasiven arten die auf
der eu-liste gelistet sind und diese
invasiven arten sind gebiets fremd das
heißt sie sind in regionen unterwegs wo
sie eigentlich nicht hingehören durch
den menschen in irgendeiner form
verbracht und da sie in den regionen
keine fressfeinde haben breiten sie sich
ungehindert aus und ja das führt dazu
dass sie dass wir menschen uns irgendwie
überlegen müssen wenn wir sie schon
hierher verbracht haben
was machen wir denn damit und
der punkt keine fressfeinde in berlin
ist auch so ein bisschen fragwürdig und
deswegen haben wir uns mit unserem
konzept gedacht wir machen die menschen
wieder zu fressen die berliner zu
fressen und wir essen die roten
amerikanischen sumpf krebse aus
das heißt eigentlich die grundidee des
ganzen ist aus einem schädling also ein
nutztier zu machen ja genau aus einem
schädling insofern als dass er natürlich
die das gleichgewicht aus der also die
die natur aus dem gleichgewicht bringt
aber gleichzeitig ist er natürlich eine
delikatesse also kommt aus louisiana da
wird er gegessen
da wird auch teilweise in verschiedenen
ländern gezüchtet heißt wir haben es
hier mit einem lebensmittel zu tun was
extrem hochwertig ist und da liegt der
gedanke natürlich sehr nahe was ihn auf
zu essen und was ist was sinnvolles
damit zu machen und ist der kleine rote
krebs den jetzt die lösung oder ist ja
nur ein teil von ganz vielen invasiven
arten oder anders gefragt welche gibt es
noch die vielleicht auch zum verzehr
geeignet werden also wenn man sich ein
bisschen näher mit dem thema beschäftigt
dann stellt man tatsächlich fest es gibt
unglaublich viele invasive arten und ein
großteil davon ist tatsächlich auch
essbar
wir arbeiten noch mit der chinesischen
wollhandkrabbe dies in der elbe
unterwegs wir arbeiten mit dem
graskarpfen der es auch in der müritz
und in verschiedenen seen im umland von
berlin unterwegs
es kann auch noch so ein bisschen in die
fleisch richtung gehen also mit real
kennen vielleicht viele im frankfurter
raum bis zum nil ganz unterwegs die
frist die grüne soße kräuter weg da sind
die frankfurter ganz fuchsig gut
invasiver arten zu verzehren ist jetzt
eine möglichkeit müssen wir uns auf
jeden fall auf ein anderes verhalten in
zukunft einstellen
auf jeden fall also wenn man sich
einerseits natürlich natürlich also
bewegung in der natur anschaut
klimawandel unsere art und weise wie wir
lebensmittel anbauen wird sich extrem
verändern in den nächsten jahrzehnten
und da müssen wir natürlich gucken was
was sind dann überhaupt noch pflanzen
und tiere die sich in unseren
breitengraden wohlfühlen und die wir
ohne großen aufwand auch wirklich bei
uns anbauen können und halten können und
andererseits verändern sich natürlich
kundenbedürfnisse also kunden legen
immer mehr wert auf gesundes essen auf
regionales essen auf biologisch
angebautes essen nachhaltiges essen und
da wird sich in den nächsten jahren noch
einiges tun und ich glaube solche ideen
und konzepte die diesen widerspruch
aufheben zwischen ich möchte mich gesund
ernähren ich möchte mich nachhaltig
ernähren aber ich möchte auch einfach
genießen
in der hinsicht wird sich einiges tun
und diese konzepte werden
in die zukunft welche sind denn die
wichtigsten wege die wir bei der
ernährung sehr wahrscheinlich gehen
werden oder beziehungsweise die wir
gehen müssen was sind so die großen
trends also große trends gibt es immer
da wo man mega trends beobachten kann
also habe ich schon angesprochen
megatrend gesundheit megatrend
nachhaltigkeit aber auch megatrends
konnektivität individualisierung also
die arten wie wir uns ernähren werden
sich extrem ausdifferenzieren also
verschiedenste menschen gruppen haben
natürlich verschiedenste bedürfnisse und
so wird es ganz ganz unterschiedliche
ansätze geben wie wir uns in zukunft
ernähren große trends die man da
beobachten kämpfen kann sind natürlich
die insekten aber auch ein weiterer den
ich sehr sehr spannend finde es eben das
künstliche fleisch nicht nur dass das
fleisch ersatz aus pflanzen sondern eben
auch das künstliche fleisch direkt aus
dem labor aus stammzellen gezüchtet
weil das sehr sehr stark den widerspruch
auch aufhebt zwischen tierleid und
genussvolle ernährung und letztendlich
kann man natürlich in diese richtung
gucken auf der anderen seite ist es auch
einfach in die kostenfrage irgendwann
also wenn wir diese technologie so weit
entwickelt haben werden dass sie
tatsächlich günstiger ist als der
herkömmliche
der herkömmliche massentierhaltung dann
ja ist das auf jeden fall einer
zukunftsweisenden nicht unsere ernährung
ist stark kulturell geprägt obwohl die
küche immer internationaler wird was in
asien oder lateinamerika gerne gegessen
wird finden wir oft ungenießbar aber
schon unsere französischen nachbarn
essen anders als wir dort gilt die
weinbergschnecke als delikatesse bei uns
war die schwäbische aus der
jahrzehntelangen fast vollständig von
den speisekarten verschwunden
genauso in österreich aber in wien
kriechen jetzt die weinbergschnecken
wieder ganz langsam auf den speiseplan
der zukunft schnecken wohin das auge
reicht 20.000 stück gibt es auf andreas
kugler bauernhof im speckgürtel wien
denn die noble delikatesse feiert ihr
comeback österreichs erster schnecken
mauer züchtet schon seit zehn jahren die
kleinen kaltblüter verließ sogar der
hand und wird damit immer erfolgreicher
für ihn sind schnecken das essen der
zukunft
schneck ich mich dass future food
schlechthin denn oder als tierisches
protein man braucht nämlich nur einen
bruchteil an ressourcen an land an
futtermitteln als zum beispiel der
schweine oder rinder die sich in feldern
und am wegesrand tummelten krieche haben
eigentlich lange tradition in österreich
schon im mittelalter galten sie als
klassische fastenspeise und wurden von
allen gesellschaftsschichten gegessen
doch in einem 70er jahren geriet die
schnecken metropole wien in
vergessenheit
dem wird in google muss hoch bistro nun
mittels traditionellen gerichten mit
schnecken twist entgegengewirkt als
ragout gulasch oder süßspeise werden
schnecken serviert auch traditionell mit
kräuterbutter schmecken sie den gästen
großer geschmacksträger
egal was ich das schnecke bei geber
durchschnittlich mäckler training wo sie
gebraucht wird verarbeitet wird auch in
nobelrestaurants hat sich die schnecke
ihren weg zurück auf die speisekarte
erkochen wo lange taube und rehrücken
zubereitet wurden verlangen gäste nun
immer öfter nach der delikatesse schnitt
sogar brot verwandelt die schnecke ihnen
nobles mal google books schnecken kommen
gut an
die leute lieben ist und natürlich ist
es noch viel schöner nicht die schnecke
frage ich zu kaufen oder sondern
wirklich keine schnecke zu haben die in
wien produziert wird nun heißt es
abwarten für schnecken bauer google mob
sich das kriechtier neben rind und
schwein auf den tellern etablieren kann
doch eines ist klar er und seine
schnecken haben viel geduld
wie also wird unsere welt in zukunft
aussehen wie leben wir arbeiten dir was
essen und was trinken wir viele fragen
wir werden weiter versuchen sie zu
beantworten auf unserem weg in die
zukunft
dennis 20 47 würde ich sagen da war ich
noch nicht flugs kompletter an
[Musik]